MARK MIRCHANDANI: If you
have a large team working
with your Google Cloud
Platform resources,
you may want to make
sure you set caps
on the amount of certain
resources that can be used.
On this episode of
"Beyond Your Bill,"
we'll talk about what quotas
are and how to set them up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Budgets allow you to
trigger notifications
so that you know how your
actual and forecasted costs are
trending over time and prompt
you to take action if needed.
Quotas allow you to set
your own capped limit
to the number of concurrent
resources in a project
or the number of API requests.
Quotas are important to protect
the community of GCP users
and safeguard against
unforeseen spikes
in usage that could
lead to budget overruns.
There are two types of quotas--
allocation quota that
measures that a resource,
like the number of
virtual machines
you can have spun up at
once, and rate quotas
that reset after a
certain amount of time,
like API requests per minute.
Most resources and
APIs in each project
have quotas set by default,
and some can even be unlimited.
But you can also
configure specific quotas
to help manage your
cloud resources
and establish cost controls.
For example, let's say you
have a test environment where
a lot of users have
access to BigQuery.
Since it is a test
environment, people
may be a little less
careful about optimizing
their queries, which may
result in some costly mistakes.
So you may want to set
up in a quota limit
to ensure that
each user can only
query a certain amount
of data every day.
Let's check out how to view
your current quota limits
and how to modify an
existing quota limit.
In the GCP console, you can
use the top left navigation
to select Quotas
under IAM and Admin.
Since quotas are
set per project,
you may need to choose a project
if you haven't selected one
already.
You'll also need to have
the right permissions
for the project, such as
project owner or editor,
in order to change
any quota limits.
The Quotas page
contains a large number
of quotas across all the
GCP products and services
available to you.
There is a lot
here, so you can use
the filters to narrow down the
quotas you're interested in.
Filtering by type lets you
choose between unlimited quotas
or quotas with usage.
Service, metric, and
location filter down
to just quotas matching
what you select.
For our example, we'll start
by filtering to just BigQuery
to keep the list manageable.
You can click on the
drop-down by Service,
click on None to
deselect everything,
and then click on BigQuery API.
Now we're just looking at
BigQuery related quotas.
Each row is a
different quota and you
can click on a quota to go
to the API specific quota
page, which may show
graphs or other details.
On our current
project-wide quota page,
each row starts
with a description
of the quota, then the
location or regions
that the quota affects.
After that, the current
usage and peak usage
over the past seven
days is shown.
For allocation quotas,
the current usage
is how much of the resource
is currently in use,
while for rate
quotas, it's the usage
so far in the current day.
The last column is the actual
limit enforced by the quota.
The first row item, Query Usage
Per Day, shows us how much data
we've queried today in BigQuery
and that there's currently
no limit set up.
If we edited this quota,
we could set a limit
on the amount of data
that could be queried
for day for the entire project.
For our example, we want to
limit each user on the project.
So let's select the Query Usage
Per Day Per User quota instead.
We'll select the check box
and then hit Edit Quotas
at the top of the page.
It's also possible to edit
multiple quotas at once.
On the right side
of the console,
a form will open up where
we can input our limit.
Some edits may require
you to fill out
contact information and a
form to request the limit
update rather than modifying
the limit directly.
Quota requests are typically
handled within two business
days and an email
confirmation is sent out
once the requested
update has been reviewed.
For this quota, we can easily
lower it from unlimited
to any number we want without
needing to make a request.
Let's limit each user
to half a tebibyte
of data queried since that's
the metric that BigQuery checks
for quotas and for pricing.
With a quota limit
set, there will now
be a limit for each user
when running queries.
One important note is that the
Quota page doesn't show you
the current usage
for every quota,
such as the per user
quota that we just edited.
Check out the link
in the description
to see more about setting
up monitoring for quotas.
To test out our limit, we
can run a query in BigQuery
that is projected to process
much more data than is allowed
by our limit.
BigQuery returns back this
error showing us the quota
has been exceeded, so
the query won't run.
We can also run
smaller queries up
until our quota
limit, at which point
we can't run any more
until the next day.
You can set the quota
limits that best
match your desired
usage caps across many
of the GCP services.
It's also possible
to set up monitoring
for quota metrics in Stackdriver
so that you can create
custom dashboards or alerts.
Check out the Monitoring
Quota Metrics link below
to see how to set this up.
Now you should be able to
view your existing quotas
and update quota limits to
protect against surprises.
Check out the links
for more information
on working with quotas.
[MUSIC PLAYING]